as things heat up between channing tatum
and zoe kravitz a source tells et
they're still going strong and both very
happy yeah it's true it's true quote
channing is so supportive of zoe's
career he is such a fan of hers both in
their personal relationship and
professionally speaking as an actor it's
happening it is happening it's happening
et source adds that while they both have
hectic schedules their understanding of
that and make it work quote channing
goes out of his way to make sure zoe
feels loved and she does the same for
him not only does zoe love channing but
according to et source the actress's
family loves him too and thinks the
lovebirds are a great fit i'm really
blessed man
need proof
get this earlier this month the magic
mike star who has been dating zoe since
at least august
joined jason mamoa to see his real-life
leading lady play catwoman in the batman
i can take care of myself
at the time the aquaman star shared this
snap with channing on instagram writing
that he was beyond proud of zoey of
course jason and zoe's mom lisa benay
tied the knot in 2017. it's beautiful to
go through so many different
challenges in our lives and have a
partner that loves you through all of it
so but they recently announced they're
splitting after more than a decade
together
still though that family bond seems
stronger than ever not only did channing
show up to support zoe at the box office
he's also supporting her behind the
scenes too the 41 year old actor
recently told et he gave his girlfriend
some advice when it came to their
upcoming film [ __ ] island a film she's
directing and he's starring in the
advice
don't direct and star in the flick
something he did with his latest film
dog
the deal shake
just don't think you enjoy it i didn't
get to enjoy really directing because i
don't feel like you know i'm sitting in
the bronco and you know trying to sort
out the dog you know reid is talking to
our dp and figuring out the next shots
and like what the next decisions are and
like what they're getting and
you know i'm sort of in my own little
world over there and i just i i think
that
it's
you need twice the time if you're going
to be in the movie and last month zoe
told et she was glad she listened to her
man
i'm absolutely not starring in in that
film it's hard enough to to act on on
your own i don't know how people do both
i will not be in the movie i'll just be
directing it one thing at a time
[Music]
you